anime can get pretty gruesome but what
terrific shows are worth your time well
from tales of malevolent spirits to
portraits of people shattered into
inhumanity these are the most terrifying
anime you can watch donar guys devil man
manga has been adapted more than once
per 2018 stable man crybaby might just
be the most terrifying adaptation of
them all directed by masaaki yuasa this
version hues closer to the manga than
others and incorporates uses trademark
character focus resulting in a story as
emotionally potent as it is horrifying
Akira and Ryo friends since childhood of
a series central figures Ryo convinces
Akira to become the titular devil man to
fight off an Asian race of demons but
all is not as it seems and what unfolds
manages to shock them among newbies and
diehard fans alike death disfigurement
violence of all am Vivat display here
the series penultimate episode go to
hell you mortals as an absolute parade
of grotesque curries wherein beloved
characters are mutilated killed and
reduced - desecrated body parts but
devil man crybabies true nightmare is a
gulf that opens between Akira and Ryo
despite their careful planning best
intentions and literally divine power
this isn't just a horror story about
man's inhumanity to man but about the
destruction of love itself of the hands
of selfishness and cruelty horror isn't
typically considered a beautiful genre
but moto know Kay is a gorgeous series
by anyone's estimation consisting of 12
episodes Mononoke tells the story of a
nameless medicine seller who hunts
Mononoke spirits across feudal Japan
Mononoke can be easily slain however the
medicine seller must first understand
the form they take and why they took it
before he can dispatch them what results
as an anime of uncommon psychological
depth human nature is a source of all
the scares in Mononoke and as such the
lines between good and bad a profoundly
blurred the series visuals which
resemble 2d paper cutouts intensified as
horizontal approach to horror
there's no locale that looks normal and
to such terror creeps in with rare
subtlety everything from ukiyo-e
woodblock stas nouveau is incorporated
into modern okay style and you can't
help but marvel as its aesthetic
flourishes as a grisly scene in faults
but that's the point of the anime serial
experiments lain follows lain ear Akua a
14 year old girl living in
in Japan who has a quiet life upended by
an email from a dead student the student
claims not to have actually died but
instead abandoned her physical form to
live within the wired over the course of
13 tense episodes Lane goes from
introverted girl hood to outright
omnipotence in a world with a boundary
between the material and the virtual
afraid to nothing serial experiments
lain is first and foremost a work of
science fiction but it commits so
wholeheartedly to exploring the
possibilities of artificial intelligence
that it becomes a work of profound
horror reality Lane argues as a thing
people agree on and if that consensus
can be manipulated reality will be
altered lain in the audience alike a
granted no quarter as anime delves into
the nature of a world ruled by in human
intelligence whose influence can't be
stopped
every time Lane sits at a desk her slim
figure dwarfed by the reef of screens
the viewer understands that the world is
changing in a way we aren't prepared for
Satoshi Khan's perfect blue is among the
most influential anime to ever exist
Madonna incorporated clips of it into a
2001 drowned world tour a director
Darren Aronofsky we made a scene from
perfect blue in requiem for a dream why
this far-flung influence it's simple
perfect blue is a masterpiece of dread
Mima our protagonist has just left a pop
idol group to become a serious actress
births as threatening faxes pour in and
the websites entitled Mimas room
containing dari entries purportedly
written by Mima herself gains momentum
Nima realizes not all is as it seems
the events of perfect blue are
themselves horrific but it's constancy
approach to their portrayal that make
perfect blue the nightmare 'it is
frantic cuts to Soria and the viewer odd
scene changes mimic Mimas increasingly
disordered mind and mirrors screens and
windows refract a world that has lost
its meaning Mima descends into an
underworld of illusion and the viewer
only has her perspective to rely on one
that draws into question the reliability
of reality there's a culprit held to
account at the end of perfect blue but
their actions are only part of the story
the real terror and Mimas mind and the
viewers lies in her world's collapse
Cope's parties longer bloody history
began in 1996 as a simple PC video game
today the corpse party franchise
encompasses manga spin-offs live-action
films and drama CDs corpse party
tortured souls as 2013's anime
adaptation of the beloved series years
before the series beginning
only hosts elementary school as a site
of a series of brutal kidnappings and
killings though it was raised a new high
school was built in its place and filled
of teenagers who don't understand the
malevolent psychic energy that surrounds
them until they find themselves trapped
in a nightmare version of heavenly host
Bob's party as a brutal bloody series
that rebels in the macabre
it's got spilled innards severed tongues
and bifurcated bodies if you can stomach
this is a satisfyingly savage tale of
the past long shadows and the youth
forced to grow up within them the trauma
they've inherited isn't their own but
it's their job to process it anyway
Shiki which chronicles the destruction
of a small town body and human monsters
that live in the mansion on the town's
outskirts is a classic vampire story the
Shakya hypnotic and dying figures of
inhuman drives a certainly another
bullet they are eerily similar to
everyday people those who were killed
are reborn as shiki megumi the first to
die goes from being a small-town girl
with big-city dreams to being an undead
killer with disdain for a hometown
this might sound familiar but what makes
Shiki a truly memorable work of horror
is the truth of the Shiki themselves
that's hard the Shiki just want to build
a peaceful home the turkeys actions are
fire but the anime never shied from the
truth of their tragic situation they
exist they must feed and they're trying
to find a way to do both with a minimum
of cruelty the impossibility of
reconciling these things is what makes
Shiki such a resonant horror story no
longer human began as a 1948 novel by
legendary author Osamu Dazai and this a
story as powerful as it is challenging
to adapt yet 2009 saw that accomplished
when Ali bunjaku a 12-episode anime
series featuring adaptations of popular
Japanese literature devoted the first
four episodes of its run to animating no
longer human though Ali Bangkok you
takes liberties of its source material
the core conceit remains intact
protagonist yo so he feels completely
detached from everything that makes one
genuinely human watching him
disastrously failed to connect as a
truly harrowing and relatable portrait
of brokenness his life might not be
anything like the viewers but as in the
original novel almost anyone can see a
little of themselves in Yozo that's what
no longer human forces us to view
through yo Zoe's inhumanity in this he's
far more human than he realizes and
that's the most terrifying thing of all
years before the events of another a
student in yo Miyama middle school
suddenly dies her classmates reeling
with grief pretended as og
at all to the point of reserving a seat
at graduation
this culminated in the deceased
classmates mysterious appearance and the
class's graduation photo years later a
boy named Co Ichi begins his time in the
same class place due to illness and he
discovers that something is amiss
Misaki a quiet classmate is entirely
ignored by the other students and then
one by one hurry cheese peers start
dying Misaki is the only one who isn't
surprised by these tragedies and only
she understands how to stop them the
animes moments of violence terror and
dread make it the sort of Nightmare any
horror fan can enjoy but their true
power lies beyond brief thrills they're
the pillars of the story central tragedy
the class is locked with a cycle of
grief that can only be broken by that
most crucial thing acceptance their
inability to do so it's a series truest
by Mayor of all to be young and in love
happy sugar life addresses the virtues
of this sublime state only to confront
the viewer with the reality of its
starring couple Sato a teenage girl with
a hard luck past and she oh the kind
hearted eight year old Sato keeps locked
in her apartment
satella will do anything to conceal and
protect the happy sugar life she
believes she's created for her and she
oh this is a love of pristine purity
calling to sato and there's no evil she
won't commit in her devotion to as
preservation happy sugar life never
glories in the details of Sato's
grisliest acts this animate she'll serve
viewers with a vision of just how people
can twist each other into monsters Sato
exposed only the most dysfunctional
relationship models as a child believes
that kidnapping a child is excusable in
the name of true love but it is shears
character arc that really terrifies
having known only abandonment and
violence so far in her short life
she can't recognize Sato for the monster
she is nor identify herself as an
individual beyond what sato projects
upon her what results is a story about
how entirely people can destroy the ones
they love and just someone visible the
process can be an alternative ending to
Neon Genesis Evangelion s controversial
final episode The End of Evangelion
shows us the apocalypse nerve the
paramilitary group responsible for the
Evangelion units other heroes pilots is
being used by its commander Gendo Ikari
to hasten the end of the world he
succeeds not as he would have liked
prickly Oscar is disemboweled quiet Rey
attains biblical power and joins all of
humanity into a single consciousness
protagonist shinji survives yet the
story ends on a shot
of him an Oscar alone in the ruined
world it's implied that humanity Mart
reform but in the moment shinji attempts
to strangle our skirts of death when he
fails Oscar matters the last line of the
film which is most often translated us I
feel sick or how disgusting the end of
Evangelion is possibly about hope but
mostly it's about the vanilla tea of the
world the corruption of the powerful and
the inevitability of decay shadow star
nerrit aru begins as a tale about a
pigtailed every girl and her mysterious
alien friend Ho Chi Maru you might be
thinking of this sounds like Digimon or
Cardcaptor Sakura a story of youngsters
and their unlikely companions saving the
world with their supernatural bond this
is very much by design hoshi maru is
adorable sheena is a cheery charmer and
the opening theme features purposefully
childlike drawings of the cast alongside
their alien friends its sweets it's
bright and it features a lot of
harmonica somehow shadow star now Ataru
begins this way and then ends 13
episodes later as one of the most
graphically disturbing anime series of
the 2000s characters are beheaded
impaled for Suri maggots of their
severed heads mounted on dolls and
experience a whole host of other grisly
Horrors too graphic to be described
shadow star nor itaru is in the end a
series of absolutely glorious and the
worst things people can do to each other
watching it is dizzying as moments of
grotesque horror often juxtaposed
against scenes of peaceful daily life to
say nothing of sheena whose blue head
perky nose becomes more and more
discordant as a series darkens its
abrupt ending Oni makes a series more
upsetting shadow star Naruto charms
horrifies and then some was inexplicably
ends the viewer is left to absorb all
the unfolded on screen with little in
the way of explanation and definitely
nothing resembling comfort check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos buy your
favorite anime are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]